oh god this is heavy  i bet these are my mom's books  i just texted her it turns out she's not  home  i can't find my mom anywhere  she's not home  all by myself  don't want to be  all by myself  anymore  [Music]  god did i hit that [ __ ] oh my god i hit  that [ __ ]  mom your book's here my books here yeah  your books here  where is it where is it where is it it's  on the counter inside okay  [Music]  all right what do you think what if  there's a typo  isn't it  [Applause]  at that oh you picked the cover i told  you too i did  look at no that's beautiful  holy [ __ ] that's like for real  are you gonna sign my my copy  are you gonna buy it  mom are you asking the hard questions  look at that  it's legit that is like a legit book  hannah it worked  i can't believe it ellie look  look ellie  look i'm an author  do the author dance do the author dance